[Music]
[Applause]
the hall of famer barry sanders joining
us on behalf of rocket mortgage super
bowl squares sweepstakes barry uh
sanders joining us on the program mild
mannered barry sanders
look at that
just
barry and engineering joining us on the
ground here
you ever get confused that's the nicest
thing you've ever said about me man
really in engineering yeah i think so i
think so okay it's good to see you
though man good to see you do you ever
get confused for anybody do they think
you're somebody else on the streets
um yeah i've been called a lot of
different folks like who you know like
oh you're you're that boxer guy or
something like that a boxer
okay
or you know being called deion sanders
[Laughter]
better athlete you're
oh
i mean
if if we're being honest here um i mean
he did he did play like two professional
sports okay
but you could have played college
basketball
uh well again he played two
professionals
okay i appreciate that man better thank
you man better better football player
between me and diana
hey i'm i got dion on tomorrow so
whatever you say you do wow yeah okay
man i i that's that's a tough call man
let me let me call you back later no
come on
i never even hey dion man he has like
several ring how many rings does he have
well you got a few yeah yeah but he you
stayed with one team that's why you
didn't get any rings he kept bouncing
around
you weren't loyal get it done man i
didn't get it done you know that's all
there is to it i mean you know i got to
give it to the guy with the rings you
know i'm i'm never going to say i'm
better than deion he was he was such a
phenomenal um you know i know you know i
mean obviously he'll he'll tell you how
great he is
what about no bo jackson
between
what
dion and bo between the oh wow
man that's that's a tough call
as far as better athlete yeah oh wow
i would probably say if i had to pick
one
um
because there's just two choices right
yeah
whoa
yeah bull
absolutely bo
would you i'm sorry dion would you
rather be your size or bose size at
running back
well growing up i would have said
absolutely bo jackson size yeah yes
give me that all day yeah i'll take that
but
you know you would sometimes be able to
squat down or be behind the line and
then you would they they couldn't see
you bo
you saw bo
yeah i think you know it's nice to be
able to like in both case run over a guy
or run around him just take your pick
just depends on how you feel that day i
mean
did you but you didn't
didn't try to run over guys did you
um
no i tried to avoid that part right yeah
i tried to avoid that part of it unless
i knew it was a small guy
i was also wondering so you see stafford
he gave everything to the lions but then
he was like hey can you help me get out
like did you ever broach the lions and
say
you know what maybe maybe i just can you
can i go to another team and i didn't no
never thought of that back then not
really no not really i i just pretty
much uh hung up the cleats
um went on about my business but no i
never i never had that sort of a
conversation and michael irvin was
talking about tom brady when you
announce your retirement
and he thinks that tom is probably
having second thoughts about like you go
home and then you're like now what do i
do
what was it like when you you're that
first month when you retired
well i mean it was it was a challenge
just because there was a lot of um just
media attention
um
and uh
and so yeah i mean
you know i realized that uh yeah i mean
those are those are kind of difficult
days just
trying to understand okay you know i
just retired did you get depressed i
normally i normally
no i don't think so i don't i think i
was ready to leave
at that time i think i was really ready
but it certainly was an adjustment i
mean you know because you realize that
okay now normally now i'm in training
camp
um so which actually if i was depressed
you get over your depression real fast
when you get you missing you're missing
training caps
does emmett smith ever thank you for not
taking his
record does he ever just say barry thank
you for not playing longer because you'd
be the all-time leader
i mean he hadn't said it in those words
but he should
i don't know hey look i love i love hey
emmett um he's a good friend you know i
see him all the time um you know it's
it's interesting because
you know we i see him at card shows and
stuff like that and they're like all
these people that know him not from
football but like from dancing with the
stars
[Laughter]
did you get a better dancer did you ever
think about being on dancing with the
stars i never did no
did you that's something that yeah did
they ask yes they did
really
i don't think you have any rhythm do you
i mean it's got to be in there somewhere
no no no because you told me you never
celebrated in the end zone
because you you didn't have the rhythm
to celebrate
where you did something like that yeah
something like that yeah i mean
i don't know i mean but would your dad
have been mad at you if you did all of
those
you know dances and things michael irvin
stuff and after scoring a touchdown oh
yeah he would have definitely had
something to say about that yeah he
would definitely have something to say
about the different things like that but
it also it was just my you know my
personality you know that's that's how i
played the game um i never really even
thought about it
doing something um you know and as a
running back growing up
um what what more is there to do but
score a touchdown you know it's you know
um so so yeah i never thought about okay
yeah what else am i gonna do in addition
to doing that um you know
so i don't know you're right i mean you
did what you're
should you
be drawing attention
i'm paying you to score touchdowns
and then you score a touchdown and then
you want somebody to notice that you
score a touchdown right what am i paying
you for
well i always thought the job was done
but hey but you know teach his own
that's how i played the game um you know
but i probably probably also you can add
in there i just didn't have any rhythm
as well so
would you rather be a running back for
the bengals or the rams would you rather
be joe mixon or cam akers
um
i would think
i mean that's that's a good question um
i would probably say
bengals
i think i think joe mixon's probably
gonna get you know he's probably gonna
see more action even though cam acres
has um done a great job and they they
use him you know um but but you would
think that joe mixon is going to get
the most action of any running back um
in in this game employment out of the
back field too catching passes yeah he
said joe he's been a good pro running
back for a lot of years um you know so
but yeah i would say joe
he's barry sanders the pro football hall
of famer uh with us usually every super
bowl talk about rocket mortgage super uh
both squares here you want to give the
pitch there
absolutely yeah my friends at rocket
mortgage are just giving away more cash
again this year
with uh super bowl squares um so um you
know the way it works is every score
change someone wins fifty thousand
dollars
they're going to have two grand prizes
that they give away at halftime and at
the end of the game of five hundred
thousand dollars um so go to
rocketmortgagesquares.com to learn more
about it the entry window closes this
friday
at uh this friday midnight uh we're done
um and again it's free to play so um
you know a lot of great reasons to play
you can maybe maybe win some cash most
of our favorite team probably not
playing in the big game yeah but you
know a great way to be interested in the
game and
maybe walk away with some cash
who are you rooting for
i'm kind of leaning toward um stafford
and the rams i mean i i you know i love
just i i i feel like matt probably has
as much to prove as anybody um in this
game but obviously the biggest lions
don't get a partial win we don't get one
you should have a super bowl parade in
detroit if matthew stafford win he might
not show up but you can just take a
little bit of credit i think i think
there's certainly some lions fans that
are absolutely taking some credit right
um i i know for me it's just i love
seeing a great player just put in a
great situation to be successful
um and to see everything
just fall in place around him um to me
that's it's beautiful to see that you
know because i can't i can't even list a
number of times people come up to me and
say well you know if
when when matt was in detroit is he the
answer you know can he win the big game
so i think he answered a lot of those
questions this year
uh the dance uh i sometimes allow them
to ask questions so uh paulie i'll start
with you all right two-part question
what when you're
playing was there what was the team
where you go oh this is gonna be a fun
week
this will be a great week for you
personally rushing and do you ever hear
anything during a game when you
torched somebody twist them around where
you could actually hear them
say something like they knew they're
burned
well the first part um
the first part uh you know
what's that the team that you knew you
were going to get 100 i think
oh okay because i saw it as sort of a
different question initially because
obviously there's a great lot of great
teams and defenses this is the opposite
now right where you just went i think i
think probably early on maybe just i
love going to tampa bay
um
you know leaving detroit
in december or whatever it is going down
um to play uh there
and they weren't they weren't the best
in like you know mid 90s early 90s so so
i had a lot of really good games against
them did you ever
hurt anybody's feelings on the field
where you you actually
i try my best absolutely i try my best
to i know but it's it's really not in
your personality but you did embarrass a
lot of people
yeah
right
right i mean okay
but no hey look when you're when you're
you know when you're a big target out
there um you know you got to you got to
do what you got to do to survive man you
know so you know how it is oh yeah i do
i i still i still love that story that
uh
barry switzer tells
about when thurman thomas was at
oklahoma state
and barry said to his team whatever you
do
don't hurt thurman thomas because barry
sanders his backup is better than him
did you hear that story i love no i
always loved hearing that and i and
those are some just great times for me
because i i love being at oklahoma state
and just each year i got a little better
um
you know and and i love being therman
thomas's backup i mean uh you know i um
i went in there and there were a ton of
running backs from texas and oklahoma
you know and growing up in kansas like
okay those are the places where football
players you know they grow them um you
know so
so but each year you know i got a little
faster stronger bigger i moved up the
depth chart and
you know and and by the time i was a uh
you know sophomore or so then i was
firmly implanted as thurman's backup and
so i left a good impression on some
folks if they're if they were saying
that about me so yeah todd you got your
question for barry sanders i do who's
the biggest trash hooker because you
were so elusive someone that really
would put a good stick on you and had
something to say or mumbling it as you
uh go by or went back to the huddle
where you're like uh wow this guy's got
a little too much to say
um the guy who's
a big trash talker i mean there's a lot
of guys but like charles haley you know
you just knew he was just like crazy you
know
you know because he he's a guy that you
know just just non-stop talking and
threatening you and all kinds of stuff
and and obviously the guy has four or
five super bowl rings but wait how would
he threaten you like he was gonna
kill you
you know i mean something like that yeah
pretty much yeah
yeah something like that okay i mean so
yeah so i would say he was a big trash
talk girl um you know there was a guy
um for green bay he was a linebacker
earlier in my career i can't remember
his name jamie harris or something like
that
um he was another guy that just non-stop
talking trash um you know but but uh
charles haley was definitely up there
with with the best of them see do you
have a question for barry before we uh
say goodbye uh yeah if you didn't go to
oklahoma state where would you have gone
um if i didn't go to oklahoma state i
would have gone to probably um either
iowa state or tulsa those are my three
options oklahoma state iowa and tulsa um
and tulsa was probably um as close to
where i grew up in kansas
um you know they had a decent i mean
they're decent now but they had they had
a decent team back then um
you know and i probably would have
played earlier there and so that was
that was one of the that was one of the
schools that that uh
the next school probably in line to
oklahoma state yeah i'm gonna guess you
probably would have played a little
sooner than you did at oklahoma state if
you went to tulsa i think so yeah i
think so
i i think so you would have been the
greatest running back in tulsa i'd have
to go back and look at their like roster
and see who was there
uh i hope the family's great it's great
to see you barry sanders on it uh
joining us on behalf of
rocketmortgagesquares.com
thanks for stopping by
dan always great to see you man great
thanks for having me thank you thank you
if you're watching on peacock when we
take a break i'm going to ask barry if
he can put some moves on the dents let
us know sort of how he did this
a few years ago are you capable of doing
this without pulling a grinder or
something
uh do i get a chance or something
you can
all right we'll take a break back after
this
[Music]
frank still playing anything where is it
is he i don't know recently dan we got
the video okay as as always we do have
these patreon oh boy no offense standard
definition
oh that's not nice you should send him a
gift basket
that's not nice
did they win that game probably like
they want the patriots
i think they don't they always yeah
that's true yeah
that was okay so
is that scott mitchell
so this move right
there
to there
let me understand
paulie will be the defensive player so
when when you're
running
okay he's like if i was younger look at
that okay look at this
face look at that expression
okay but how do you need how do you read
somebody that you know
how you're going to make a move
i didn't play a lot of football i'm
going to guess you're coming to the
right on this one yeah
he's leaning a little bit you know
but let's say i'm running
and things like that but hey you you
maybe give him a little jab step to see
if he'll go for it right you know give
him a little jab step and if he goes and
i'll just go the other way right right
no
sometimes sometimes you know or you give
him a jab step right you go jab step or
you spin or something
if there's two defenders are you
splitting them or are you trying to get
around the outside of one or the other
there's two your worst nightmare if
there's two of these two coming up
i think if there's two then you you you
pick like the weakest link right you
pick the weakest link
yeah
all right let's go get him ready oh